[تصفيق]
ارحب بكم من الاسطبلات الكبرى لقصر مرساي
هنا تستحضر رائحه التبن والخيل حكايات
مشوقه من تاريخنا فضيله قرون كان الحصان
اثر بالغ في حياه البشر في اوقات الحرب
كما في السلمين لحظات ويرفع الستار اهلا
بكم في اسرار
[موسيقى]
في نوفمبر عام 2011 ادرجت اليونسكو فن
الفروسيه الفرنسيه على قائمه التراث
الثقافي للبشريه
وللروسيه قصه طويله كتبت بعض فصولها في
اكاديميات فرنسيه كاكاديميه حيث نصور
اليوم المزيد حول تاريخ الفرس والفروسيه
في هذا التقرير
ضفاف نهر دجله قبل ثلاثه الاف عام على وقع
حوافر الجياد تدافع الجيوش الاشوريه عن
مدنها جنود الخياله تشكل قوات النخبه
وجياد عرباتها
ركيزه المنظومه القتاليه
ففي العصور القديمه كان الحصان اساسيا
للتنقل وللحرب بفضله ازدادت سرعه البشر
وتوسعت رقعه غزواتهم
قبل خمسه الاف عام بدا تدجين الحصان البري
فيما يعرف اليوم بكازاخستان ومنها انتقل
الى الصين في اسيا الغربيه فاوروبا
وافريقيا وخلال القرون الوسطى طباعه
الفروسيه العربيه اساليب ركوب الخيل في
اوروبا فعندما دخل المسلمون الاندلس
والصقليه في القرن الثامن جلبوا معهم
الركاب التي عززت ثبات الفرسان على جيتهم
واكتشف الفرنسيون هذه الركاب على خيل
اعدائهم عام 732 عندما صدى شعر المختل
تقدم الجيوش الاسلاميه في مدينه فرنسا
وبما ان ظروف الحرب تستدعي ان يكون الحصان
رشيق الحركه ومطواعا نشات في ايطاليا في
القرن الخامس عشر اكاديميات لترويض الخيل
ثم انتقلت في عصر النهضه الى فرنسا حيث
صارت الفروسيه جزءا لا يتجزا من تربيه
الملوك والنبلاء ولم تعد غايتها الحرب بل
تهذيب اداء الناشئه الارستقراطيه فعرفت
بفروسيه البلاط وفي القرن السابع عشر صارت
فرنسا مركز هذا اللون من الفروسيه وباتت
اساليب الترويض اكثر رفقا بالحصان تتلافى
العنف الجسدي تماشيا مع تعاليم ابي
الفروسيه الفرنسيه عطوان
معه تدرب الملك لويس الثالث عشر على اخضاع
جواده قبل اخضاع حشيته
وفي عهد الملك لويس الرابع عشر كانت
اسطبلات قصر فيرساي تعج بمئات الخيول من
افخر الجياد وقد انشا وزيره
مزارع للخيول لتحسين السلالات وتهجينها
لاسيما من خلال تزاوجها مع خيول عربيه
ورغم بلوغ فروسيه البلاط ذروتها في القرن
الثامن عشر الا ان اساليب الحرب الجديده
جعلتها قليله الجدوى لاسيما مع ابتكار
البروسيين استراتيجيه هجوم سلاح الفرسان
فبرزت في فرنسا فروسيه عسكريه حلت تدريجيا
محل فروسيه البلاط اللي استعراضيه وهكذا
في القرن التاسع عشر كان اعداد ضباط
الخيال يتم في اكاديميات الفروسيه
العسكريه فيما انتقلت الفروسيه المدنيه
الى دوامات الخيل ومادين السلك
اليوم تراجعت الفروسيه العسكريه لصالح
فروسيه رياضيه
ويرجح ان هذه الفروسيه ستتراجع بدورها في
السنوات القادمه لصالح علاقه جديده مع
الخيل تضع رعايه الجواد ورفاهيته في
الصداره
[موسيقى]
نحن الان في ميدان سباق الخيل الشهير
لوشون الذي افتتحه الامبراطور نابليون
الثالث
سباقات الخيل كما نعرفها اليوم بدات فعليا
في القرن التاسع عشر قبل ان تصبح هذه
المنافسه رياضه اولمبيه مطلع القرن
العشرين تاريخ سباقات الخيل نوجزه لكم في
هذا التقرير
عصر هذا اليوم الربيعي تتاهب ثله من
الفرسان لسباق الموسم المنصات تعج بابناء
الطبقه المخمليه السيدات تحت مظلات انيقه
والرجال يتبخترون بقبعاتهم العاليه
وتعود مباريات الخيل في فرنسا الى القرون
الوسطى عندما كان الفرسان يستعرضون
مهاراتهم في مبارزات دافيه لكن لابد من
انتظار القرن التاسع عشر حتى تظهر سباقات
الخيل بصورتها العصريه وقتها كانت هذه
الرياضه رائجه في انجلترا فتدفقت كلمه
وجدتي حتى فرنسا حيث سحلت البرجوازيه
والارستقراطيه وشيدت لها ما ياتيني السباق
الكبرى
وكان الانجليز قد حققوا قفزه نوعيه في
القرن الثامن عشر عندما نجحوا في مزاوجه
خيول انجليزيه بثلاثه فحول عربيه تم
استجلابها من الشرق الاوسط ومنها تحذرت
اجيال من الجياد تجمع بين قوه الخيول
الانجليزيه وسرعه الخيول العربيه
فنشات سلاله جديده تعرف بسلاله ثروبريد
وهي خيول السباق المهجنه الاصيله التي لا
تزال حتى اليوم اسرع سلاله خيول في العالم
ولو انها تعاني مشاكل صحيه ناجمه عن رابط
الدم بينها فخمسه وتسعون في المئه من هذه
الخيول تتحذر من فحل عربي واحد
وهكذا في القرن التاسع عشر بدات فرنسا
بتربيه هذه السلاله لتحسين ادائها في
السباقات كما قامت بتهجين سلالات اخرى في
مزارع الخيول الوطنيه جمعتها لاحقا تحت
مسمى حصان السرج الفرنسي
في النصف الاول من القرن العشرين تالقت
فرنسا في فئه الترويض بفضل الخفه التي
تميز المدرسه الفرنسيه للفروسيه لكن بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه صارت الصداره
لالمانيا مع اساليب ترويض صارمه لا تزال
تسمح للالمان حتى اليوم بتبؤ المراكز
الاولى فيما تحرز خيول السباق الفرنسيه
نتائج مشرفه في مسابقات قفز الحواجز في
العقود الاخيره شهدت مسابقات ركوب الخيل
مشاركه نسائيه متعاضمه فالفروسيه بمختلف
اختصاصاتها من الرياضات النادره التي
تتبارى فيها النساء جنبا الى جنب مع
الرجال في المسابقات ذاتها
[موسيقى]
نحن الان في المدرسه الحربيه للفروسيه
قرون جرت المعارك على صحوه الجياد قبل ان
تختفي الخيول الحربيه تدريجيا بعد الحرب
العالميه الاولى مشاركه الخيل في الحرب
والقتال قصه يرويها لنا المؤرخ
الذي وضع عده مؤلفات حول هذا الموضوع
دونك
[موسيقى]
زعما
مليون
[موسيقى]
لهذا ناتي الى ختامي هذه الحلقه عن تاريخ
الخيل والفروسيه من اسطبلات قصر شانتي
اودعكم واضرب لكم موعدا في حلقه جديده من
اسرار باريس الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]